hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the apocalypse where we
die in this episode this is gonna be the
name of this part is we die in this part
I don't even know if that's true yet no
started oh wait we started and the
episode is we die in this part so
somehow we're gonna die in this part
just oh you know you're on board oh no
no no wait wait what we're gonna die in
this part I don't want of you here what
is going on there always through Wade I
think we're gonna die wait where we're
safe
alright fine way do you do that I'm just
gonna dig okay like there is no tomorrow
can we make a Frick frack shovel please
yes dear
thanks honey did Molly just look over
now okay no goal posts wobbly because
you feel sorry for Vicki oh come on
don't be like that just because you're
having so much fun surviving the
apocalypse with me does not mean that
you need to be concerned about anyone
else
alright shovel is almost done you need
any scrap metal no I got a blips round
up here okay is there nothing but dirt
it's like dirt dirt and dirt where is it
other all right thank you
dearest love of my life
welcome what do you say that giggling
like sighing breathing little girl noise
really I don't know what the hell that
is just a little bit off oh this works
out so much better
Oh with the easy shovel to a 9000 we can
clear so much more dirt I said word
water at our last place
you're leanin luck because I have some
water how much do you need
I've got some I thought you needed some
no I'm good I'm just uh I'm actually
gonna carve out like an underground
chamber down here okay that was a good
idea right
sure is it cuz I don't know what
wait will they dig down here and find me
it's daylight we're good
oh it is all good all right let's get
out of here ah I think I could have
survived another night with you
good thing the name of this episode is
we die at the end or we die in this part
or whatever it is we die this is the
happiest dog are you okay
wait but don't worry I'm standing for
help oh good I'm back of where we first
started
you walked right in front of my gun well
I thought you were breaking out the one
sighs oh you you did being a zombie was
behind me in the shop I didn't mean to
I'm sorry I'm back where we started to
the evidence will clearly show in my
part when everyone watching this will
see that I did not mean to shoot you you
walked right in front of me I thought
you were going out the other doorway no
you go and then I go you worried and
then you and you caught some bullets in
the back of the head the details are
sketchy no one can say what's true but
in the end of it you were dead you've
been trying to do this in season two
you're right Rick you're right
wait a minute season two what this isn't
- I've missed her you know it's been so
long I can't even remember what's going
on what season two is
yeah that was the walk in the woods that
no one needs to know about huh
by the way if you haven't picked up by
now we spoil a lot of things in the
walking dead so if you're have you been
waiting to watch it
where are you waiting well wasn't
waiting for it's been like 18 years guys
yeah come on I mean come on it's not our
fault that um they birthed the zombie
baby and then Cthulhu came out of the
prison and ate everyone's dolls
I mean con everyone knows that everyone
saw that I mean if you didn't was crazy
I mean I couldn't be believe it and she
lived like who's crazy and then she like
got in this huge death match DBZ style
like they flew in the air huh oh except
they couldn't use kamehameha dama dama
I think he's pronouncing that correctly
someone expert check his pronunciation
on that but I yeah I believe you're
correct hey wait wait a good solid four
minutes of bullshitting the weakest
guess until we met up wasn't that good
I'm glad we're back here oh you just
want to live in suburbia
did you ever grab any of my stuff but
that was on the ground I grabbed your
shotgun but I couldn't carry anything
else cuz my inventories pull I'm
dropping your shotgun bloody okay I hear
a puppy
you don't hear nothing okay got it thank
you
alright so it's almost night again by
the way Oh
biscuit so we're gonna have to do is
forgo all options and try to I don't
know what warn me before you lose that
are you okay you seem a little on edge
well I believe the back of the head you
a little nervous about someone with an
axe
yes
you always say that you step right in
front here have some painkillers I'm
dropping painkillers they're on the
ground over here take them they're yours
I'm sorry I'm sorry you walked in front
again I was just pretending to swing at
your head and it just so happened that
what what you say it just so happened
that it worked yes no one can say who
killed who there's really nothing that
can be said no one knows your bottles in
the toilet oh well that's lovely but I
mean our campfires up here let's just
sing some songs is it we picked the
right house yes we did actually we
picked the right house there's actually
blood on my ax I wonder whose it is if
you got infected blood in me I probably
did you have any wood to block this up I
have burnt wood that'll do okay that'll
do that'll do Pig
why bother being picky at this point you
seem a little tense there wait what this
whole house is made out of burnt wood
apparently well this game freaks me out
and I just got shot and it was an axe by
you recently and you're my best chance
of survival at the same time so I'm kind
of like bipolar at the moment I'm happy
that you're back
Terrebonne don't need to be so worried
around me up and I'm down and I'm all
around that song uh you're yes then
you're no I think I think so I think
that's later here maybe then you're
possibly then you're lukewarm and then
you're kind of cool and then uh
something else
yeah but dabba-doo let's survive what is
sounds like it's burping for a really
long time isn't that that exploder
doodad oh I hope not
I'm just I'm assuming you've told me
about it I don't know about it but have
you not seen him no I saw him he was the
cop and he was all blue
all away and then I got goop in my ears
and then poop goop not poop don't be
obscene Wade oh oh
honestly so undead zombie fetuses eating
aware of their mothers acceptable but
it's perfectly fine but I mean come on
don't be obscene Wade god this guy over
here i yeah that's what I thought anyway
I'm gonna dig a hole in the floor
wait what we're on the third floor what
good will that possibly serve oh no I
wanted to don't ask me why or how I
wanted to are you down there
no wait uh oh I thought I start your
name tag down here you want to come down
here with me
let's play a game of spleef Wade hello
we're almost done with this episode and
the episodes name is we die in this part
in this part Wade I stay we go out in a
rousing blaze of glory okay okay okay
Wow God oh my god Oh reloading shoot
shoot shoot shoot shoot we're good we're
good
are we you're using us yeah yeah why is
it nice why did you waste buddy wow that
police officer did I got my axe
no I got you you do good there's a lot
of bodies to loot I guess rap what you
get back up
outside why there's so many dead bodies
around here oh wait oh wait don't leave
me down here kill that one I got the
rest hello
I need to reload same so bad actually
we're doing pretty good so far so good
so far so good my health slow but you
know I don't what happened to the police
that did he like blow up in a room of
them or something so huh weird yeah blow
up right here where this job oh oh I see
man that guy stop into the stairs I did
some dip whoa what the hell that crawly
bastard good eye oh yeah what were we
worried about there's like nothing to
worry about out here that's cuz it's
almost morning
there's nothing to worry about here
already jeez are you still alive
wait are you still alive what where I'm
coming wait what we die in this part we
didn't die well you did but I mean when
you shot me the head oh whatever it's
okay
so yeah dawn of another day good good on
you wait what are you doing wait wait
what are you doing with that you're
gonna kill me it was a defense
I survived I'm obviously the better
Stefan is it okay anybody guys everyone
watching this is the last part of our
recording session so um I want to be
very clear we were really trying to
progress but with the ten minute day
cycle it was really hard by the way Wade
can attest to this we were really trying
but um it was just absolutely ridiculous
trying to get through the 10 day
10-minute day cycle so if we actually
want to like progress in this what time
do you think Wade what Wow god damn oh
darling honestly I mean what is it BAE
what's the baseline 20 minutes um I
think the baseline is 20 I'm not sure
probably about that I mean you know
we're getting through here we're just
not making much progress as far as
building anything yeah because we when
we go out we can't actually do anything
oh I spawned back in the place because I
had a big bed yeah why didn't you get a
bed I don't know all right so anyway
guys we actually did try but this was a
lot of fun I hope you enjoyed it and I'm
sure there are better guides out there
than two [ __ ] joking around the
entire time but we entertained more than
we're good at things not always we are
good at some things but I mean it's just
not this one in particular right now in
this link once yes we did and we did it
well tied it a little bit doggie so
anyway thank you guys so much um if we
if we pick this up again we will try
very hard to make sure that we do
progress in some way and that may mean
longer episodes I'm not sure how we're
gonna do it but for now this is the end
thank you wade for joining me thank you
thank you everybody for watching check
out Wade Sam for his POV and as always
you in the next video hey guys so I
don't know what the dealio is with that
but I need to go find some sticks to be
able to make a pickaxe because I need a
lot more rocks for a quest like Bear
Grylls okay so can I pick up my campfire
or is it
what's with brick and stone I'm not